a group of teenaged camp counselors play
truth or dare and the game almost
immediately turns to dares that send one
member of the group to kiss another it's
the last night of camp and the
counselors are stranded until morning
making this the last opportunity to make
any sparks fly like nearly every teen
horror movie just as soon as the
relationships start to form and the kids
start to get comfortable
the screaming begin
maybe it was the bears and why does
everyone blame everything on bears you
got anything better i mean like zombies
aliens
time hopping draculas
for the quarry the latest story-driven
horror game from supermassive games the
somewhat predictable setup is partially
an homage to 80s era horror and teen
slasher movies like a nightmare on elm
street halloween and of course friday
the 13th it's also partially a case of
not fixing something that isn't broken
in fact a lot of the quarry will be
familiar to anyone who's played
supermassive's other games 2015s until
dawn or the three games of the ongoing
dark pictures anthology series
supermassive has a pretty specific
formula that works for its brand of
cinematic adventure game and it doesn't
deviate from it with the quarry meaning
that if you like its other games you
should have a fun time with this one
oh my god
the quarry sees you playing out the
story of the counselors at hackett's
quarry summer camp with your perspective
shifting between the different
characters from scene to scene you make
decisions for the characters in the
scenes you control them choosing between
different possible dialogue lines or
making calls like who to kiss when your
inevitable dare moment comes up the game
tracks those choices and how they might
change the flow of the plot or affect
the relationships between characters
which you can view in various menus to
see how the path you're taking through
the story is shaping up
okay
i got this
that shotgun's got a hell of a spread be
careful we played about an hour of the
quarry seeing a little bit of two of its
early chapters like supermassive's other
titles choice is a big element of the
proceedings not every decision will
create a massive shake-up to the story
but even making a few different dialogue
choices in the small portion we played
made notable differences in
relationships or scenes that we saw play
out also as in supermassive's other
games the quarry has its share of action
sequences in which you need to watch and
react to what's happening on screen
matching your button presses to the
prompts that appear as part of the
action quicktime events have been a
staple of supermassives games since
until dawn so this isn't a surprise
although the ones we saw in the quarry
feel simplified in comparison to some of
the developers past games qtes are often
maligned because they can be a real pain
to deal with often giving players too
little time to react to prompts and
causing failures in the quarry qtes seem
to be made pretty easy to deal with
alleviating that frustration as with
past games failing qtes has consequences
that can change how the narrative plays
out but it seems like supermassive has
casual players in mind as well as
hardcore fans of its titles making
playing the game comfortable even for
people who might have a harder time
handling a controller
oh that's a nice chair i could get used
to this you better hope mr h doesn't
catch you taking his baby out for a
joyride
where the quarry breaks a bit with
supermassive's usual approach is having
a slightly heavier emphasis on combat
mechanics specifically on shooting
firearms usually supermassive's games
are all contextual while there might be
moments that could be called combat like
firing a gun or struggling with an enemy
they're usually just additional qtes the
quarry suggests it'll emphasize those
moments a little more than usual even
including a quick combat video tutorial
to teach you how to use firearms in the
game
point to you nick the portion we played
included a scene in which a couple of
characters have a shooting contest with
a shotgun and then later included a
moment in which we could shoot at a
villainous character in a heated moment
how well you shoot or whether you shoot
at all is as consequential as other
gameplay interactions or decisions and
the shotgun has a wide spread so it
becomes pretty ineffective at long
ranges and might risk you hitting
something or someone you didn't mean to
if you fire it at the wrong time still
even though there's more focus on
shooting than in past games you probably
shouldn't expect combat in the quarry to
be something you engage in a lot in the
scene we saw shooting was really another
decision point opportunity pushing you
to act fast in order to do any damage
with the shotgun when you have the
opportunity to use it or to consider
whether you should resist pulling the
trigger instead if you've played the
other supermassive games all of this is
pretty much to be expected as mentioned
these elements have all proven to work
well to create scary cinematic
experiences and supermassive always puts
a big emphasis on player choice and
player success and failure to craft its
stories so it's possible to create some
distinct pathways through its past games
depending on what you decide to do along
the way that seems like it'll hold true
for the quarry as well although our
preview didn't quite give enough of a
look to really see how decisions will
cascade or relationships will affect the
flow of the plot it is
pretty spooky down here though and it
smells very unnatural so
yeah okay i'm coming back up
what was clear however is that the
quarry nails the feel of the movies on
which it's drawing most of its
inspiration the game is populated with a
lot of fun well-drawn characters with
possibly the most star-studded and
expansive cast yet for one of these
games the performances in the preview
made what could have been some
relatively hackneyed teenage drama feel
organic and relatable hey don't let the
cute preppy aesthetic fool you it's like
a steel barbecue grill under that shirt
so you notice that too huh
the entire game is also presented as if
you're playing it on an old 1990s pc and
watching scenes poorly recorded on vhs
tapes when you make a key decision that
will affect the plot for instance things
slow down for a moment the picture
tracking skews as if the heads of your
tape player were a bit dirty and the
pixelated words path chosen appear in
the font that used to be emblematic to
vhs players on-screen menus those small
visual throwbacks to movies and media of
the past are a nice unobtrusive touch
that do a lot to help sell that classic
slasher feel
you're not scared of clowns
no they're
they're funny you think this is supposed
to be funny the quarry feels a lot like
until dawn in all the ways that make
that game a lot of scary fun you've got
your teen character drama your sticky
burgeoning relationships and your
inevitable gruesome murders all the
elements that make teen horror stories
like this work we didn't get a chance to
see any of the features that could make
the quarry stand out from supermassive's
other games such as the movie mode that
allows you to make general choices about
the story ahead of time and then just
watch them play out without interacting
but the familiar elements and tropes of
the developers titles and the movies
that inspire them all still work as well
as they did seven years ago which make
the quarry seem like it'll be a fun if
slightly more casual teen horror romp
through dark woods filled with vicious
creatures
[Music]
you